hey David you've spoken about whether
people born outside the US but
naturalized as citizens should allow be
allowed to run for president
what about age should there be a maximum
age to run for president okay so let's
think this through what's the principle
at play behind minimum ages to run for
president the idea would be as a society
we've decided that some people are too
young to have the right combination of
knowledge and life experience and maybe
work experience or experience in the
world to make good presidents so a
minimum age is established for being
President of the United States so what
would be the idea of a maximum age a
couple different ways to think about it
one would be humans have a sort of
limited life span currently and we want
we believe it's in the interests of
society to have presidents that are not
super close to what is typically the
upper limit of the duration of a human
life we could make a sort of cognitive
argument we could say well studies show
that once you get to 67 68 69 even
without dementia we're not talking about
dementia but there starts to be some
degree of measurable cognitive decline
in terms of not just physical things
like reaction time but the way that the
mind responds to new ideas and
information and that's something that's
regularly a part of being president of
the United States or maybe the limited
physical abilities that start to develop
as we age are relevant in thinking about
who should or shouldn't be president of
the United States so in general people
who want an upper age limit on
presidents tend to talk about between 65
and 80 right 65 would really be kind of
on low end others saying once you get to
80 years old but we should have a
president who's younger than 80 the
scientific argument to be made would be
the first one I made which is there is
measurable cognitive decline not
dementia but slower decisions
reduced ability to assimilate new
information less clear thinking and in
most people it becomes measurable around
age 67 according to one study that I
looked at I don't think we need this
quite frankly the campaign process
itself is pretty grueling at this point
18 months 24 months depending on how you
want to measure it of campaigning all
over the country a lot of problems would
become clear between the rallies and the
interviews and the traveling whether
their cognitive or physical however it
doesn't actually seem to stop people
from winning as we saw with Donald Trump
a guy who seems to be cognitively
limited if not as a result of decline he
might have just been that way his entire
life so I think that what we would be
better off with because remember to
change to create an upper limit for
being eligible to be president you would
need to amend the Constitution which
sets out the minimum requirements to be
President of the United States that's
very difficult to do I think we just
need more mandatory transparency in the
same way that states can decide that in
order to be on the ballot in their state
a presidential candidate needs to
release their tax returns something that
Donald Trump didn't do we could make it
a requirement to release full health
information and that would get around
these obviously bogus health reports
about Trump that he's just so healthy
and not obese and would be the
healthiest president in history or
whatever the case may be mandatory tax
return disclosure mandatory full health
report disclosures and then let the
people decide I don't think we need a
maximum age in the law and that would be
much more difficult to achieve from a
legal perspective let's make it
mandatory that we actually get full
health reports and while we're at it
let's do the taxes as well since we
still are curious about that with the
current President of the United States
senri our thoughts if you disagree that
we if you disagree and believe we do
need a maximum age tell me not only why
but how you would institute it if you
disagree with me that we don't even need
more transparent health reporting about
presidential candidates and presidents
tell me why I want to hear from
everybody
disagreeing vote on all levels and from
both sides we've got a great bonus show
for you today thanks for joining me get
access to the bonus show david
pakman.com slash membership as well as
patreon.com slash david pakman show